[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thank you for
listening i hope you're enjoying your
week i uh thank you for spending time
with us um
uh what can i say it means a lot to me
and if you're here
for ming na when i hope you'll stick
around i hope you'll like the interview
enough to say hey i'll give this guy a
chance and listen to other episodes
because i think you'll learn something i
always learned something i guess learned
something
so i appreciate you guys listening make
sure you subscribe
and follow us on
instagram facebook and twitter ryan tell
them about where the handles are oh they
can find it at
insidetheviewpod on twitter at
insideable podcast instagram facebook
that's exactly right
and if you want to join patreon to help
the podcast in other ways
people like to give and i appreciate it
go to patreon.com
inside of you i'll send you a message
after you join there's a lot of tears a
lot of
great things to patreon it's become a
big family a lot of people have made
friends on it
so many people have become friends
and uh
anyway that's a lot of fun and i will be
at the motorcity con with tom welling
we're doing a smallville nights so get
your tickets go to motorcity con
and uh that
is uh october like the weekend of the
15th whatever that is
cool
yeah so that will be fun it's always fun
to do a convention with tom and
you know meet fans and um all that stuff
do smallville nights act out scenes um
today's guest
ming na wen i mean you know her from the
mandalorian she's fennec shand
uh i believe she's on the boba fett
series that's coming out uh she's so
open and honest and i really like how
she opened up and i wasn't sure she
would so thank you
uh
ming you are amazing and i love having
you in the podcast she talks about
meeting mr rogers when she was on mr
rogers show and doing soap operas and
street fighter and
mulan and
she's done just about everything you can
imagine and she's really fascinating and
i think you're going to enjoy this
so let's just dive into it let's get
inside
ming na when
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
haven't heard that one before
ever ming na
what have you not heard what give me
three that you've heard
what of ming na wen or just uh how
people have effed your name up
oh ming nee
like really like do you call tina tinay
do you call donna madonna madanei i mean
come on it's so stupid
ming nee um what uh what what are the
ones oh not when of course i get that um
is now win
oh yeah you don't like it you don't like
when people mess your name up
well i mean you get used to it you know
yeah you rosenbaum come on
huh rosenbaum i heard so much [ __ ] when
i was a kid rosenbaum raisin bran rose
and
boom
uh rosie palm
but see like my name it's spelled
exactly the way
it
sounds yeah ming now when
yeah rosenbaum
i mean unless there's an accent over the
a people could say i mean the only name
that shouldn't be pronounced correctly
is your first name
my michael because it's not spelled in
any way shape or form
the way it sounds that's just really
look at it it's like
a [ __ ]
in spanish i think it's mikhail okay
people are probably tuning out now where
are you by the way
um i am in the only room currently in my
house that i
that's not been broken into i'm i'm in
the middle of a massive remodel right i
mean are you in new york
oh
oh that's great i meant where where like
in new york right
no i'm in l.a you're not well why don't
you just come here
because
i don't have to travel
i was literally moving boxes and
furniture and all sweaty like an hour
ago
into a shower blow dry my hair threw on
a little lip gloss and then meet you see
well i couldn't do that if i traveled
well i've had the pleasure of meeting
you many times
yeah we met at the cons we always have a
laugh you are really like i don't want
to say a dude but you're like so cool
that anybody can come up to you and you
could just you you
you throw whatever right back at them
you just got this quick energy about you
well
okay
is your husband kind of the straight one
and you're kind of like uh
he you know you're the it depends on it
depends on the situation
it really does because he could do
stand-up really if he wanted to really
why why do you think he's that funny or
oh yeah he's he's very funny that's one
of my requirements
is you have to be funny well how long
have you known him
how long have you been married
we've been married all
i have to count
over 25 let's say because i love how you
say that's my requirement like you get
married every two years
it's not a requirement and you've been
together for 25 years this is like well
we've been we've been together for
twenty
eight maybe
what year is it almost thirty
did he hit on you or did he's
twenty-eight did he hit on you or did
you hit on him no it was the strangest
we met in the stranger's way literally
it was because of joy like club
um they were doing
a special screening
of joylet club
in la and i had just come out just to
try out what la was like because i was a
new yorker
and um
i don't know why i didn't ask my agents
at the time for car service to take me
to the screening
right um and you know back in those days
you don't have gps you don't have cell
phones you don't have
you know you remember the thomas guides
oh yes i still i never could read those
wait i never did
okay so
um i
i didn't i didn't know where to go
really and you know it's not like new
york where you hail a cab and you just
jump in and you go somewhere there was
no uber right really back in those days
so i called up the people that i knew
and one of them was my acting teacher
from carnegie mellon
and um
he said i can't take you let me find a
nice
chinese boy to take you what he really
said
i was like well he doesn't have to be
chinese
like literally he was setting me up
wow he was he was my what is it what did
they do tinder what what
i guess tinder or uh raya or bumble or
whatever whatever yeah so he was that
for for me
so you got hooked up and like how did he
charm you well when he was driving you
around right
yeah well he was driving me to a
screening and he thought i was like an
extra because like why would somebody
need a ride from a total stranger
right
and uh so we get to the theater and um
all my other girlfriends the other
actresses you know from the movie um i
hadn't seen them in a while so we all
wanted to have dinner because we had
already seen the movie a couple of times
so i ushered him off with the publish
i'm like okay go enjoy the movie i'll
see you after
and he was literally my ride and you
didn't think he was cute or anything you
weren't even thinking like that i didn't
find him that attractive all my other
girlfriends found him very attractive
because for me in my mind i literally
thought he was just a dude that was
giving me a ride to the theater right i
was very new york i was a total new
yorker you know
and then we got together and uh you know
ended up talking for like three four
hours so so you ended up marrying your
driver falling in love with your driver
yeah
that i met him and he was a sweet guy
good looking man
thank you and i met him at a convention
he went with you to a convention
does he not does he enjoy the
conventions or does he choose to stay at
home
no i did not marry a geek
surprisingly
[Music]
i mean
so opposites attract you know opposites
attract yeah he really
he
he's patient
but uh he doesn't really get into all
this stuff how do you feel how do you
feel about cons how long have you been
doing cons and how do you feel about
them
well you know who who um introduced me
to cons
is um um
um
oh my gosh i'm so tired and and
dehydrated
that
why am i blanking out on who introduced
you to general
adama
um
who introduced jesus
oh my god
wait say it again it's hilarious
people like this [ __ ] this is fun
oh my god i am so having a senior moment
you're great you're you look fantastic
you're doing great this is this is uh
you just being you having fun
edward
james
almost almost
he's going to kill him no he's not he's
not going to listen to this first i am
so i'm so funny well anyways um
adama i'm just going to say
general adama general
obviously that's all i associated with
battle star right uh battle story right
that's who we played um we met at a con
and he brought this up and you know
about well you do you do cons and i'm
like
i don't want to do cons it just feels
weird you know
to like sign autographs and take
pictures and and have people pay for it
but then he's like well do you pay for a
concert
and i'm like yeah he's like well
no one's putting a gun to their heads
you know it's like for them it makes
their day and for you
it you know you get to connect them
connect with them in a different way
yeah yeah
and you just started doing it i think
that's what happened to me i didn't know
what to expect and then
when you go there i i was always what
you call a geek i was always the guy who
went to conventions to get autographs
and get toys and things like that and so
when i was able when they asked me to go
i was like really i'm gonna do this i
can't believe i was nervous that they
you know i couldn't imagine anyone
showing up to get my autograph and
it was pretty fascinating and then i
felt like
they're here because this is a vacation
to them they're taking the weekend off
to see all their the people that they
enjoy to buy to cosplay it's just
like yeah it's just fun it's so much fun
so i i totally get it and now you've
been doing it for how many have you done
you've probably done a hundred
no
i
no well you've done a lot
i've done a lot but not a hundred and do
you like them
i love them
i love them i love being able to
like be with the fans and
the craziest thing is when they cry in
front of you tell me about this like
you're the beatles or something and it's
it it's this moment of
wow i've made some impact on certain
people's lives that's kind of cool you
know have you ever cried back were you
ever touched where you cried or you
teared up
yeah yeah
do you remember what it was
there were several so um there was this
one
gentleman who um actually gave me a very
special necklace
and it was like a greek coin
and um
and
it's sort of like it protects you and
gives you strength and power and
confidence
and i was like no no no you can't give
that to me that's for you because it
meant so much to him because it's given
him so much
that sense of confidence and and you
know because we're all geeks and we're
all
like introverts
really um so
and i was like no no no you can't give
this to me
and and he's he's you know he started
crying he's like no what you've done in
your you know as mulan as you know all
these characters has really been so
impactful
and i started crying because
he
he was just so yeah i treasure that
necklace and the coins for confidence
yeah it's like confidence and strength
it gives you could i have the coin
sure i could use something it does it
doesn't mean anything to me now
it was just meaningful it was a moment
it was a moment
it's past
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
say it with us blue chew
blue chew is bringing more confidence to
the bedroom by offering chewable tablets
that can help men get stronger and
longer lasting erections
that's right i don't know who you are i
don't care who you are but the there's
always an issue there's always some
issue arises whether you you've been
with the same person too long or you're
getting older or you just
you lose it man
sometimes you just lose it and what do
you need you need a blue chew
let me tell you about blue chew guys let
me just tell you about it it's a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in a chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost bluetooth tablets help men
achieve harder stronger erections to
combat all forms of ed that's erectile
dysfunction yeah i'm talking about it
i'm confidently talking about it because
we all experience it it's all happen
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy and it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part
it's all done
online bluetooth licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient and strength for your
prescription don't like swallowing pills
no problems here so if you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit
bluechew.com and here's a special deal
for our listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code inside at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluechew.com
promo code inside to receive your first
month free and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring the podcast inside of you is
brought to you by m1 finance
look up in the sky it's the finance
super app invest with powerful tools and
unmatched automation borrow with some of
the lowest rates or spend your
hard-earned cash from their secure
digital checking account m1 finance does
it all all with a few taps in their
sleek modern app it's no wonder money
investopedia and yahoo finance are
raving about this app or that hundreds
of thousands of investors have trusted
over 5 billion in assets on the platform
they say you shouldn't always go with
the flow but this tidal wave of cash and
savvy financiers might be on to
something plus get a thirty dollar bonus
to your m1 invest account when you get
approved and funded with one thousand
dollars within your first
14 days
go to m1finance.com
inside of you to get started that's m
the number one
finance dot com
m1 finance dot com slash inside of you
investing involves risk including the
risk of loss
borrowing on margin can add to these
risks rates may vary terms and
conditions apply inside of you is
brought to you by hello
fresh
uh i use hellofresh i love hello fresh i
love getting healthy meals sent to my
house
and all the ingredients ryan are there
for me i don't have to go to the grocery
store and go oh what do i need i need
some paprika is that what it's called
that's a thing yeah you know yeah i need
this or how much do i need they give you
the exact amounts with hellofresh you
get fresh pre-measured ingredients
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door skip trips
to the grocery store and count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable that's why it's america's
number one meal kit hellofresh offers 50
menu and market items to choose from
every week from vegetarian meals and
calorie smart choices to extra special
gourmet options there's something for
everyone to enjoy with recipes designed
and tested by professional chefs and
nutritional experts to ensure
deliciousness and simplicity get better
value hellofresh is over 30 cheaper than
shopping at grocery stores with
pre-portioned ingredients that ensure
you won't spend money on excess food
that ends up going in the trash and
here's all you have to do go to
hellofresh.com slash iou 14 and use code
iou14 for up to 14 free
meals including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
iou14 and use the code iou 14 for up to
14 free meals including free shipping
now look you've done so much i i
couldn't believe how much you've done i
mean mulan and agents of the shield and
joy luck club and street fighter and
mandalorian and now the book of boba
fett and er and it goes on and on and on
and
you don't look old enough to have done
all this [ __ ] first of all
but you you're in the marvel universe
star wars star gate
i mean you're kind of living the dream
in a bit i mean you're living my dream
what does it feel like to have done all
this stuff yeah i i don't know i pinch
myself every day i don't
i i mean i'm just always so thankful
for all of it is that how you go it
really shouldn't happen
to
well you know the double minority right
asian woman
and now you know ageism i mean it
shouldn't be happening like really
to someone like me
who had to learn a second language you
know coming from a different country
like if if it's any
um
if it means anything to anyone because
it means so much to me but if it means
anything to anyone that you can achieve
and fulfill your dreams
it it's that you know just
it's truly like the american dream story
it is the american dream story it's just
a great it's a great dream i mean it's
it's it's a reality for you and it's it
is it's amazing you deserve it all and
it's kind of crazy i i really it's still
it's sort of like an out-of-body
experience and i can't explain it any
other way like
every time i look at pictures you know
you go to work as a professional right
you go to work it's your job you've got
to i mean i geek out for about 5-10
minutes when i'm on set because there's
always these new toys
you know and these new images and
and so
i'm always like
like a kid in a candy store just going
crazy and then i got to remind myself oh
wait well tem
temuaro
he'll remind me but
well it's you know what's amazing to me
is
that
i mean i look at the story and you were
born is it macau
in macau that's not too far from hong
kong and your parents divorced at a
young age and you moved to hong kong
with your mom and your brother
right i mean that's the beginning of the
story and already it sounds like how did
all this happen with your life
right you know what i mean i mean how
was it did you was it tough as a kid
growing up i mean was your father
present at all or was just mom and
brother
i mean he came to visit us i keep
hitting this
hole
um
he came to visit with us every so often
but um
yeah it's
hmm
i don't remember him very much i did
meet up with him again because when i
was in my 30s i felt like you know what
i really should try to
because i kept his last name i'm the
only member in my family that kept
when
which is my
real father's last name when my mother
remarried
to my stepfather who i consider my my
true father right
for some reason they didn't bother to
change my last name to his which was yi
y-e-e
so i could have been ming-na yi
right or miznai
[Laughter]
good throwback good call back there
i don't know i mean i mean how we like
my mom just forgot i don't i really
don't maybe it was expensive maybe to
change your name was like too costly and
she's like screw this i mean my older
brother changed his last name like in
after college because of the business my
my parents ran a restaurant
chinese in pittsburgh right in case
you're wondering it was a chinese
restaurant a chinese restaurant in
pittsburgh in pittsburgh yeah
so
i don't know it's like i was d
that was the only
when
growing up
wow
it is it is odd
and then
so i think i think
part of me probably wanted
to get back in touch with him so and how
old were you when you got back in touch
with him
like i was in my 30s
and you reached out to him
yeah
and i felt really bad because michaela
was around too so he kept looking at
michaela like
michaela was me
my daughter right
and uh and i felt really bad but i mean
literally you know he was the biological
father i had
i i hate to say it but i really didn't
have any connection to him you didn't
really feel anything
no i mean i i felt sorry that his life
ran a course that you know
made things difficult for my mom but
i don't know yeah was your mom upset
i'll leave her out of it
you'll leave her out of it that speaks
volumes you know the chinese we don't
like to really
lay out our dirty laundry well it's just
you know it's kind of like what happened
and it's it's life and it's interesting
a lot of people have those journeys
where they don't know their father that
well they don't know their mother and
they grow up and how hard that is for
them and did you have a normal childhood
no
how is this dysfunctional as hell i mean
my parents i mean i love them i've
learned to just accept them for who they
are and you know i love them and i think
they they try but uh you know it's uh
it was difficult there was a lot of
dysfunction in the family but you know
my dad didn't
leave
he said i stayed there for you look how
unscarred you are
i love how you laugh
i love how you laugh right after that
because you know that i'm scared
it's like you already know me
let me ask you this
i mean we're not in this business
because we're sane because we're
adorable
we're not normal
we're not normal no we're not
what i mean how
you move to hong kong and what makes you
start to think i want to be an actress
i don't know my mom said i always wanted
to be i mean she she saw it in the stars
like or in my nose or something and she
reads face do you know the chinese we
read faces
no tell me about that
so
there are people who look at your face
yeah and they'll look at your you know
the shape of your lips and
your eyes your and they're able to sort
of
predict certain things about your future
so for me apparently my nose
your nose was i was destined for the
arts
i have an artistic nose
so
you have a great nose
thank you yeah it's mine it's yours
that's that's good i i i should probably
get something done with mine but i'm not
gonna
but what did mom if so mom influence
that she did she take you to acting
class as a young girl
no she did everything she could to
dissuade me from the arts yeah wait a
minute even though she was the one who
thought you should be an actress
do you know with with
asian moms
you know like any sort of like music
acting
drawing writing those are hobbies
they're not
they're not to become a profession that
you make a living off of
so um yeah and and of course like for
her all the horrible stories that she's
heard about actresses having to
sleep their way to the top you know she
didn't
want me to
too late mom no
i did it all
i did it mom i'm on top of the world um
jeez
no so yeah so she did everything to
persuade me so so what did you do it was
like the first thing you remember doing
that you wanted you to act in class or
what was it that got you going
an easter play in
an easter play and who did you play do
you even remember i think i was like
thumpy
yes a rabbit
did you sing
no i came on stage and tripped and fell
and everybody laughed
were you supposed to trip and fall
no
but i still enjoyed the reaction so much
so that i was like oh this is what i
want to do so i want to make i want to
make people laugh so after the show you
tripped and fell and then you said mom
this is i want to act more and she's
like you tripped and fell you were
terrible
what was it that kept you going and so
that applause that applause that
laughter right got you to the next thing
so what was the first thing where it's
like she started to allow you to start
you started doing this more and more
because you moved soon after right you
didn't live in hong kong that long
no no no um my mom met my father my
stepfather and then we moved to new york
and then moved to pittsburgh
so and when you moved to pittsburgh
that's when things started happening
very heavy new york accent no you did
not oh yes i did because i learned
english in new york queens of all places
you talked with the really because i was
born in long island
if i'm drunk or angry enough it
sometimes comes out let me hear
something like water you know go get me
some water
oh my gosh
yeah i had a very how did you lose that
by going to pittsburgh carnegie mellon
idea carnegie mellon voice class yes
voice and speech class
you were in mr rogers neighborhood
yeah
i mean do you remember it at all do you
remember fred rogers
you know what's so sad is that i
remember everything and i i'm
the fact that we didn't have cell phones
back then and i didn't bring a camera
is it
it was it just breaks my heart
because
it was incredible to be
on that set i don't know how to turn
this thing off so you're going to hear
that every so often sorry
but how there's probably a switch on the
side of the phone is it a phone
no it's the computer oh so what was it
like that you remember being on set
of mr rogers neighborhood
well
first of all mr rogers
what'd i say he's exactly the way
you see him
i mean just
sweet kind quiet soft-spoken
and i thought he was a little crazy at
first because i would hear him behind
the castle king friday's castle like
talking to himself
what was he saying but i didn't realize
he was just running the lines with his
puppets oh right right right
how old are you
i was in
wait a minute you're on mr rogers and
you're in college
yes they needed some trumpeters
and um so me and two of my classmates
volunteered
and we got to do it
and you wow so you have a vivid memory i
thought i was like wow i can't believe
she remembers all this she was a young
kid you were not a kid
no i was
i was 18 years old and i thought mr
rogers was crazy
like i literally i'm like he's talking
to himself a lot back there
did he really talk so slowly and sweetly
and calmly yes
yeah
it it it was incredible yeah to be on
that set
yeah and how many things had you done by
18 years old before you went to carnegie
mellon were you already doing plays i
already had my equity card
really
and is mom still trying to dissuade you
at this moment in time no she takes all
the credit now she takes all the credit
i mean back then when you were 18 is she
like still trying to say no as soon as i
i got into carnegie mellon
and she knew that that was a very
because you know it's pittsburgh it's
one of pittsburgh's most prestigious
colleagues
so
when i got into carnegie mellon then she
realized like oh well first she was like
oh american school is so easy
because
because she didn't think that you could
get a degree
in acting like
i
i thought you were going to say because
my daughter got in
yeah well she got in for acting
so she thought that's the easiest thing
it's a lot of work but it's like she
cannot believe that
this prestigious university
gives out degrees
for acting
so you started doing a lot of plays and
she would come see you mom would come
and support you
yeah yeah and did she see the talent did
she say
you're good no
no she never said ming you're amazing
yeah
really is that just not is it the
culture or is that just mom
it's mom
yeah it's mom has she always but now she
you know now she she says i've gotten
i've improved tremendously
is that what she tells you you've
improved after all these years
yeah
like when when mulan and joy luck club
came out
then she was like overwhelmed you know
but before then
she just
she was worried for me do you ever bring
her on set
yes how does she like that
she
she tries to underst you know like i
mean she
she's very pro but but it's almost like
an alien
world to her you know
so i don't know it's i mean it's it's
almost like i mean you've brought your
friends or
your relatives to their board after an
hour they're like are you doing this
soon again right oh my god they're
excited for like 10-15 minutes and then
they're excited about craft service and
then
like they watch you
for
the first two takes they look great and
then by the fifth one they're just like
oh damn
i gotta go yeah they're like acting
sucks it's boring yeah exactly did you
were there a lot of asian americans at
carnegie mellon in the acting program
no i was one of the first few ones yeah
that actually got in and graduated that
actually graduated i think too did you
get roles that weren't asian that they
were going to give you a chance at were
you given that opportunity to do plays
and roles that were written for white
people or whatever
no not really in fact i had to go in and
have
had we had a conversation with the guy
that hooked me up with eric going back
mel shapiro he was actually the head of
the department he wasn't just one of the
teachers but he was the head of the
department at carnegie mellon and i i
literally in my
um junior no senior in my senior year
i was like you know mal listen my mom
and dad's hard earned money
to pay for the tuition so that i could
get
a you know
a good education before i go out there i
i need
i need to have bigger parts you know
because i was always delegated to
the smaller roles right maybe because i
wasn't good enough according to my mom
or maybe you were talking like this
still you were talking like that you had
to lose i wasn't i wasn't um but
but um
you know but i was
i was very bold now that i think about
it but i just felt like my parents money
deserves a fuller education and so i i
told him that and i and he and you know
what his response was what he was like
well it's gonna be like that in the real
world man
that i would be delegated to small parts
i was so pissed at that point and that
was the mentality then and just until
recently right i mean that's yeah so i
turned it around i said well then i need
to get bigger parts in school so i could
have a better chance
i need more experience in school right
now than these other people that you
think are gonna
breeze through and get get the parts and
did you get that opportunity i got
bigger roles but i don't think i ever
got the lead
in many things
what was the biggest thing you got
after it was like a one act play where i
got to be a lead in in a in a in a group
of 1x at carnegie yeah like it was a
french farce or something that but not a
main stage but not main stage no and
that always pissed you off
no it just made me i think it helped you
know it made me feel like you know what
i'm gonna prove you're wrong
and then he hook hooks me up with this
nice guy so i can't be mad yeah i mean
your husband so
what was the first big thing you did
after
carnegie mellon
i've never been drilled like this before
this is so weird you don't like this
is this what a podcast is this is this
is what the podcast back and forth and
shoot the breeze like i'd ask you like
this is what you could ask where did you
go to school where'd you go i went to
western kentucky university i got in
with a 2.2 gpa um i
impressive yeah not impressive
a 2.2 is almost half of 4.0
almost
but this is what the podcast is you talk
about how someone got to where they are
how how that happened and what they deal
with and anxiety and life and what life
throws at you like this is
really
amazing to hear how much you had to
fight at carnegie mellon yeah this is
what people want to hear this is what
the podcast is man it's facing adversity
and uh
can i tell you this is like one of the
first
i don't think i've ever really done a
long long ass podcast really
yeah do you hate it
huh do you hate it
no no no but i i i feel like this is
like the spanish inquisition a little
bit no no it's just getting to know you
just kidding no i know i know but like
you know let me ask you this
so what was the first big role you got
after after uh carnegie mellon
um i went to new york and started doing
off-broadway
theater
and i was like with the manhattan
theater club i was with um
playwrights horizon
circle in the square
yeah yeah um
you know like i would just
dilly dally but like my first big
was as the world turns it was a soap
opera
now that's a hard thing to go into
because that's a lot of lines isn't it
it is it really
it's
like one of the actors called it
meatball surgery from uh from mash
because like literally just like you
know in out and out like just you just
was that nerve-wracking learning all
those lines
uh
i
i don't know i i mean i think
i was just having so much fun
you know it was like
and it was great because the the one
thing that carnegie mellon didn't teach
me and carnegie mellon taught me a lot i
mean i really owe a lot to that school i
and and all my all my classmates we keep
in touch with each other
you know we had a very special class and
um
so
you know i don't want to trash it too
much because
they'll probably hate me for it but they
but carnegie gave you the confidence to
to do all this
oh yeah no no no i mean okay here's the
other thing i have i have a daughter now
that goes to
college right and
i did not realize that the program that
i was in at carnegie mellon
actually
is not the normal college experience
because it was almost like a repertory
uh
company or
i mean literally i would be going to cla
like 8 30 you know voice and speech
class
9 30 uh dance
10 30
i mean we have a curriculum they had a
curriculum we had a curriculum until 3
p.m then we had rehearse we had to
rehearse
and then we had to do crew
which is
you know and a whole other evening so
like literally i was going to school
five days a week and then weekends too
like constantly like
10 10 12 hour days and my daughter would
be like
oh yeah so i have um oh i made my
schedule so i could have a four-day
weekend
and uh i have two classes on tuesday
that's my long day
um
what
[Music]
are you paying for yeah what are you
paying for
it's such a scam like i feel like i
really got my money's worth even with
the smaller parts because we we learned
to dance we learned to do like stage
combat we learn
i mean so much right so much
and and i can't believe that that's not
the normal college experience
inside of you is brought to you by geico
that's right guys geico everybody knows
geico our beloved geico here on the
podcast uh look whether you rent your
own home
or you have your own home
you know it's easy ryan
bundling policies with geico
look guys geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy it's all
about convenience guys you already have
so much to do around your house or your
apartment or whatever you just need to
make things easier bundling policies you
pay everything in one bill
go to
geico.com
it's that easy get a quote see how much
you
could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's
geico.com even a rosenbomb can do it
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy this is working i don't
know how many people have come up to me
ryan at convention saying i tried better
help it's really saving my life it's
really helping me one of those people is
helping is ryan it's helping me it's a
helpful service and you get in the name
help help better help better help and
you did you get a new therapist uh i did
um yeah just uh just recently right
because uh ryan had a therapist and so
he wanted another therapist and so
that's what happened it's so easy better
help online therapy really has done a
great job and i really appreciate having
them on the sponsor as a sponsor uh
they're just so fitting that's what we
do here we talk about a lot of things
depression anxiety look whether you're
struggling with grief relationships or
stress or you're having trouble sleeping
or meeting goals online therapy
might be for you
better help us secure online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with a licensed
professional therapist betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own accredited therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
and you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
it's really
amazing and easy and better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if you
need like ryan it's also more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'm telling
you
offline therapy is so much more
expensive coming from someone who has
gone through a lot of therapy i'm
telling you this is the way to go
it's easy visit
betterhelp.com
inside and join the over two million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional inside of you
is sponsored by betterhelp and our
listeners get 10 off their first month
of online therapy at betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside better help online
therapy try it folks
how much combat did you have to learn
for like street fighter or even amanda
lauren like how much work and how much
of it do you do do you like to do it
i love to do it well street fighter
was one of my first
big action like experience and i mean we
would train two hours in the morning
and then we would train two hours in the
afternoon and then you know like so we
would do jogging um anaerobics in the
morning and then we in the afternoon we
did um
stretches or or fight moves and then in
the evening we like
you know just trained
with
weights and stuff i mean that it was
intense was it fun playing chun li
yeah it was you liked it how did you
like working with van damme
because i hear so many things in fact i
hear from every actor there's so many
stories out there was it just i mean you
don't have to elaborate or you could
elaborate if you want again i don't
think he's listening to this podcast but
was it interesting was it funny
well i mean he was a huge star oh yeah
back then you know
and i mean between him and the the late
row julia
like
it was i mean i felt like i you know
i hit it big
so yeah he and he's he's very charming
very very
yeah he's very charming
yeah that's what you'll say
that's what i'll say that's what you'll
say
was he there for all the scenes was he
always there and giving you oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah no he's he was definitely
there for all the scenes yeah
that's pretty amazing and on er i gotta
ask i mean did you even work with george
clooney
yeah you did
the most amazing human being
how long every time you mention his name
or
like or i see him on something i i just
smile i'm just so happy for that man he
is truly
one of the nicest superstars
in the world nicest guy he doesn't even
have to be a superstar what was it about
him like when you're on set what do you
recall that you just remember him so
vividly being so kind and nice what was
it about him
everything i mean he is always just
i remember
i remember i had to do the tonight show
and he was also a guest you know and you
know how like because he's the bigger
star they always have the biggest star
first and then they leave right
well i was like ready to piss in my
pants i was so nervous because
i you know i'm really more an introvert
i thought i was an extrovert but i'm
really not and so when this kind of
stuff happens
i
i get very nervous and so my publicist
he apparently like knocked on george's
door
and told him that i was really really
nervous and was about to like just throw
up and not go on
and so george knowing that
he stayed
instead of leaving
like when like he stayed
the whole time on that set
with me
just in case like
you know like he was just
he stayed in the chair he didn't leave
as the lead guest yes on the tonight
show
you know just like little subtle things
like that that
and he's done a million other like on
set he's just do you remember him being
hunky on set
sure
but i think he's hunkier now you like
the older george
i think so yeah you do yeah yeah i mean
he was he was he was hot back then too
how long have you been a star wars
fanatic
um
ever since they came out
ever since 1977
may 22nd yes
wow
wow how about that for some precision
yeah
so you're always so if i threw out
something like can you name
three bounty hunters and empire strikes
back
could you do that
[Laughter]
you're evil i couldn't even remember
edward james almost
ig 88 boss
boba fett
um
but you've always been a huge fan and
like i saw all these clips of interviews
back when where you were like
i just want to be in a star wars movie
some interview or some kind i want to be
in a star wars movie it's something that
that's always been part of you since you
were little
yeah
and always always
always the force will the force will be
with you always always yes
did you audition for the mandalorian
you didn't even audition
so
did
which doesn't happen very often no
no
yeah but i i don't understand so is it
one day you're at starbucks
and you get a call from your agent your
agent says
i think you're going to be in a star
wars okay well i'm gonna i'm going to
give some credit to
extraordinary women
extraordinary asian women who support
you know their sisters
um i was at a party
and uh
throwback to joy luck club um tamlin
tamita
dear friend amazing human being she knew
what a huge star wars fan i was and at
that party was deborah chow
who is directing mandalorian
and she came up to me and she said you
have to meet deborah you and she knows
everybody she's like the she's the
social butterfly which i'm not
like i don't even know how i succeed in
this business seriously i don't schmooze
i don't because you're charming and you
don't know anyone
no you're
you are one of the most charming people
i have ever encountered
you light up a room immediately light up
a room i'm not just saying that when you
are in a room
everybody gravitates towards you you
have that it that's what it is
but go ahead go ahead
so she introduced you so she introduced
me to deborah debra and i just started
talking we hit it off and you know and
then she's like oh you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know mention you
two you know how people say that and you
don't ever believe that never happens
and sure enough
yeah that's do you remember the day do
you remember the moment where were you
when you got the call
oh wow
that's a good i don't remember what
happened yesterday no um
i remember
getting um
not a call like it's so weird our
managers and our agents like they just
email stuff but i think they did call me
that day
and
i read the script
and at first i was a little
sad and concerned because you know
fennec shan dies
in the script yes in lips grip and i was
like gosh i've been holding off for so
long you know what is it like
40 years but hang on hang on your first
reaction should have been like yes yes
oh yeah totally totally my first
reaction i was like oh my gosh oh my
gosh and i'm reading it i'm reading and
i'm like oh yes yes yes she's an
assassin
she gets shot in the gut and dies it's
like
oh
it just like broke my heart
so totally so what did you do you went
to set and were you did you did you
mention it like do i have to die did you
talk to anybody no no what happened was
like you know
i had a a lengthy conversation with john
favreau and dave filoni two of the most
again they're they're in the caliber of
george flooney for me
the nicest human beings you know the
kindest creative
just
saints really
um so i
i had a long conversation with them and
just loved
the take that you know they were going
with it and so i go on set i'm like you
know what this might be my only
opportunity i gotta do it right
so yeah i did
and i go on set and the costume was
amazing and you know i worked on the
hair idea with maria and we were like
really being creative about this
character because i'm like okay if it's
only going to be one episode i'm going
to make her like stand out you know i'm
gonna have this like really cool hairdo
to go it's really like i really invested
a lot into it right and i was so excited
and and um
the first time like i was on the volume
not realizing what it was
and and i got on set and literally there
was like one rock and some sand
and i was just like wow this is like you
know
it's like that's it back in the day the
black box theater
where you
yeah
99 cedar where you had one-man show
turns into a table that turns into a
chair that turns into a house you know
there was just nothing there but there
you of course there's going to be a
world in post
well i didn't know you know i was just
like wow okay not very impressive
did you say anything to anybody like is
this
these are my inner thoughts
and then they light it up
and it was this inc it was tatooine
with the binary sunset
and i freaked i mean literally i teared
up i teared up so much i was so
overwhelmed with emotions
and then i for asked the first ad kim
richards who was this incredible human
being i'm like okay i know we're not
supposed to take pictures and said but
you have to you have to take this
picture of me looking at the binary
sunset with my one foot up like luke
skywalker
and they did you have that picture she
did she like quickly took a few pictures
of me wow and that was my my my i will
forever have that moment i i was just
like i cannot believe
you're a kid in a candy store you were
back to that 1977 premiere of star wars
it's like this shouldn't be happening
you know it's so crazy and so anyways
then dave filoni who is directing this
episode gunslinger
he saw somebody wearing yellow and black
and he was like oh those are the
penguins colors
and i was like oh
you're a fan of the penguins well i love
the steelers
and he's like oh really and i'm like
yeah i'm from pittsburgh he's like i'm
from pittsburgh i'm like no
and he's like yes
i'm like where'd you go to college and
you know he went to a different call i
was like i went to carnegie mellon and
he's like uh where'd you go to high
school i'm like mount lebanon he's like
i went to mount lebanon
and that was it
that was my
my golden ticket that was your end to
for him to prevent death
or try to because it wasn't it wasn't
one hundred percent but boy
so maybe fenix shouldn't die you cannot
kill an alum from pittsburgh from mount
lebanon
i
exactly you're giving the guilt trip but
at the end the scene when you die
supposedly it would be like you you're
wearing yellow and black see yeah
yeah yeah
but when you're when you're dying there
at the end where you don't really die
but didn't i read somewhere where you
started like moving your fingers or
started no i i suggested i'm like maybe
we should do a shot where my fingers
twitch a little just to give you options
during the final edit
and when was it that you heard
you're coming back
um a few months later yeah
how enormous of a reaction i was
i was
like a gasp i mean
you know it's just
it was amazing i mean look what you were
supposed to die
in the one episode and then you're in
all these episodes and now
the book of boba fett
i know
did you know at the end of the final
episode of season two when the credits
came up and it said coming soon the book
of boba fett
what you knew before that right
i'm not allowed to say certain things
you're not allowed to say certain things
do you speak who tease
no
do you know what that is
no that's the language of the hutts so
if you said yes that would be jeez oh
okay who teased but if you said yes i
have perhaps you know
i've always pronounced that hatties is
it hatties
i don't know maybe it is but i was going
to think that if you said yes that that
that means huts are on the show
that sounds like hey you want to go to
hooties
you want to go to hey let's hit new
tease it's too easy beer get some beer
at hooties
so you can't tell me anything about the
book of boba fett
nothing
ah this water tastes good you can't even
tell me if you worked a lot
you can't tell me if you worked a little
you could only say there's the book of
boba fett
was mark hamill in those scenes in this
in the finale of season two
in a way i mean was he on set
he was
was that exciting for you had you met
him before
i've met
you want to hear how i met mark hamill
the first time i was out in hollywood
you know roger corman right of course
have you ever worked on a roger gorman
film no that i didn't realize that
that's like a a real initiation into
hollywood
is to work on a roger corman film so i i
worked on the roger corman film
see see this is what i mean i don't know
how
because i don't know anything i don't
know people i don't know
i don't know histories it's so funny but
okay so roger corman film and mark
was friends with roger
and he came on set
and i got to meet him again no camera
um
that was my first time meeting him i was
so excited and then i met him another
time at some um
uh either charity or
some sort of dinner thing nicest guy
ever
i love i love working with him we worked
on some animation together and
oh my gosh the boy right yeah you do a
lot of animation yeah i haven't done a
lot lately but yeah i used to do a lot
of animation you've done a lot of
animation
yeah i mean speaking of bad batch
right
you play fennec shand
and so what's the difference by the way
in bringing fenix shan to life in live
action on mandalorian and and the book
of boba fett versus doing the voice in
bad match obviously you're not it's a
live action there's a difference but
what do you like about both
um well when dave told me that that was
going to happen and it was going to be
like 20 some years younger
um
i was so excited because you know
there's a chance to really develop her
backstory
and uh it's so great to actually have
been the live-action
character because then when you do
the animation
one you know the character
more
and two
it's so nice to just like go
these are sound effects they ask you to
do folks when you're doing voiceover and
they go
you hit a wall we need a sound of a hit
and then you fall
there it is you drop you drop from up
high and you land on something
you said i mean if people were listening
not knowing what was going in that room
they'd say what is going there's a throw
up contest in there
but it's so much easier than actually
having to do it on set oh you don't put
makeup on you don't have to do anything
you just have a sprite or whatever the
hell you have and you just read the
lines well during covet we had they sent
all this like special equipment
and the only place that i could do it
where i had good sound buffering was our
closet
with all the clothes and i did
i did bad batch in my closet
wow
it's the craziest thing and the quality
of the sounds because we didn't really
do any adr
the quality was incredible
did someone set that up for you
um
yes my
my non-geek husband hmm pretty talented
i don't think i could have done that all
right this is called [ __ ] talking with
ming na when this is fast rapid fire to
wrap us up here uh these are questions
from my patrons my love of patrons who
support the podcast in other ways
go to patreon.com inside of you folks if
you want to join it's an amazing family
but right now uh emily asks what
character do people say is their
favorite you've done that people come up
to you
definitely mulan
and now fennec
yeah and oh and agent may
from agents of shield
which you were on for many see you've
done a lot of episodes of television
seven lots of fight scenes
lots of fight scenes would you do
another network television show that
does 22 episodes a year or you're
sticking to streaming
you know just depends on the role
on that check no
no i'm just kidding it just depends on
the project really i love it all right
nico p how awesome is to go to work and
kick people's ass for a living it looks
so cathartic
it is
yes perfect
nancy d what is the role either
professionally or personally that you
hope to be remembered for
professionally
yeah
what professionally
it's so hard to choose they're like your
children
they are but what's the one it sounds
like fennek shand is like that yeah it's
an exchange all right i'll go with that
i just because it is it's it's my dream
job it's a dream job you know
i mean i would be i i told my agent
for the last 20 years well it's been
different agents
but i
i said
i'll be a storm trooper
i don't have to be seen
right that's how i that's where it
starts
michael you you keep dreaming that
because for me i was like even if it
even if i'm just a jawa because i'm not
that tall but even
i would do it
they're saying houdini aren't they yes i
think they're sick
ray h who are your personal heroes
oh easily my mom for sure
such a survivor um
and uh
i don't know
there's so many it's it's hard to
pinpoint
it that's a cut well hobby questions are
so hard
they're great you're answering them
honestly dave plavi says when you come
home to pittsburgh
will your parents make you do work at
the restaurant
oh always
really
yes of course even today if you went
back you'd work at the restaurant
yeah if they're busy and they need
help for sure what do you do what can i
do you know they have like this shrine a
little bit of of a like with pictures of
me and stuff at the cash register
and like when i used to come home and if
i come in during lunch time and they're
super busy at lunch you know my mom
would be maybe my mom doesn't work at
the restaurant anymore but if sh but she
did back then
and she'd be like
help clean table clean table
so i'd be like you know
wiping down the table taking the dishes
going yeah there's a shrine that's
that's my shrine right up there oh man
this has been fantastic do you do you
ever get anxiety you ever deal with
anxiety or anything like that
occasionally yeah and what do you do to
help you with that
uh sometimes tequila helps but i don't
say that either
see what i mean you are you're not an
introvert
you're funny i am i don't think so i
think you're really funny but you get
anxiety and you probably exercise a lot
yeah like if i have to get on the red
carpet i have to pretend i'm beyonce
really are you gonna put this fake
literally i will go beyonce
beyonce like i will summon her energy
into me before i go like i'm look i'm
sweating already thinking about going on
a red carpet
i cannot do that
i really i do
that's my mantra before i get on
is your daughter proud of you how many
kids do you have two
i have two yeah are they pretty proud of
mom
yeah they think it's cool what you do
yes do they want any part of it and and
i'm very proud i raised at least one
nerd in the family who's the number one
son he's a nurse daughter is not yeah my
daughter's not she doesn't care about
the mandalorian she doesn't care about
this stuff
she
she likes it because now she's dating
somewhat of a nerd so yeah yeah so she
appreciates it well listen i got into it
like my son is well i i hope you enjoy
this because this has been by the way
one of my favorites this has been ryan
hasn't that's been great this has been
you have been awesome i don't really i
don't think you realize how great you
have been you're so fun and because well
you're you're easy to talk to but i i
felt like it was a one-way conversation
and i feel really bad about that no
that's what it is it's me talking to you
and you could you could always ask me
something but it's really about it's not
like about people don't want to listen
to me they listen to me when i ask you
the question
where are you right now i'm at my house
you have indiana jones is that your hero
right there no i just like it so you
know i just have an indiana jones and a
lot of horror movie posters in my
podcast room so much fun michael thank
you for asking me to do it i'm so glad i
finally got you to do it and um
when it's done will you help promote it
a little on you on twitter or whatever
no i'm not going to do that
no i won't even i'll be like michael who
you
rosen boom
she's got a good memory you notice that
how she just threw back to like an hour
ago
i like that
but she couldn't remember almost his
last name no who's ryan who's right
ryan's my engineer and uh he's over
there uh rocking it and making notes and
enjoying this interview is he paying you
enough ryan to suffer through these
boring conversations about where an
actor talks about herself all day long
hands down this has been one of the
better ones i will say that
this is a really good one nope this is
not the best so uh you're up there
you're gonna like this one there's still
a lot of 20 21 left yeah there's still a
lot of 20 21. listen i want to get more
of your time i love you i think you're
amazing i'll see you at a con or
somewhere and thank you for doing this a
lot of people are gonna be very happy
okay great well thank you so much for uh
talking to me all right bye
i was afraid that she wasn't gonna open
up so much i really i've saved this
before with other guests but um
she was i thought i thought she'd be
i think she was like do people want to
hear this do people wanna
is this i've never really done one like
this is this we're talking serious stuff
are we
and i i like that about her that she was
just sort of like going okay if you
think people
i'm telling you i i know you like that
episode um
i certainly did and uh i thank ming
nawain for being so open and honest and
uh
i see her at conventions and she's
always been great and i'm glad i finally
got her on the podcast did you enjoy it
she was fun she was really fun she was
yeah i thought it was a good one yeah i
did too i think um
you know she texts me after uh did i say
should i have not
no
you didn't say anything wrong
until she text me and say you [ __ ]
why did you air that i don't think she
would do that
but uh again thank you for listening if
you really enjoyed the episode i urge
you to subscribe and um
write a review
and uh follow us on twitter at
insideeapod at insideeapodcast on
facebook and instagram and you can watch
the show on youtube you could subscribe
on apple stitcher and so many other ways
spotify so i really appreciate you guys
uh subscribing and all that stuff
and uh if you want to join patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n
patreon.com
inside of you
and uh
for ways to help the podcast in other
ways your ways people give back and uh
again i say this all the time but i
couldn't do
couldn't do the podcast without patron
my patrons are phenomenal they're a
family and i love them it was great
seeing them in west virginia i was in
west virginia and i got together and had
some uh i got tequila shots for some of
them
and it was a good time
yes also if you wanted any band merch
from my band sunspin go to sunspin.com
and a reminder our band it's rob's
birthday bash so we're going to be
playing on stage you can get tickets on
sunspin.com
sunspin.com we're playing two shows
october 9th 2 p.m 6 p.m great prizes
great music great fun it's rob's
birthday join us guys please join us
watch the band uh you can also get
tickets on stage it s-t-a-g-e-i-t
stage it dot com type in sunspin
it's a lot of fun so now i'm to read all
the top tier patrons these are the
people that as i said give back to the
podcast in so many ways and these are
the top tiers maybe you can become a top
tier i don't know
here we go
nancy d leah asked tricia sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h mamaloran
g nico jerry w robert b jason w apophia
and kristen k emilia o allison el raj c
joshua d i got to meet joshua d emily s
he was there cjp samantha m jennifer and
stacy l
uh jen s jamal f janelle
b correct carrie b tabitha 272.
kimberly i got to i got to meet her too
oh great yeah
kimberly mike e l on soprano 99 more
ramirez santiago m sarah f chad w leanne
p
janine r maya p
maddie s shannon d belinda and kevin v
james r chris h david h dave h
spider-man chase sheila g brad
d ray
a
h o h tap of the t liliana a turd k
we've said turd k no we would remember
turd k turd are you sure it's turd did
we say that wrong someone going to not
be a top tier patron after this is it is
it a north macdonald shout out it could
be michael ferguson is that what he says
remember the celebrity jeopardy where's
turd ferguson i don't remember
michael s talia m betsy d hi betsy
claire m laura l chat l rochelle nathan
e marion meg k janelle
n sorry lorraine g carrie h veronica k
big stevie
w kendall
jenner t
angel m rhiannon c cory k and the last
list super sam coleman g dev nexon
michelle a liz i
uh jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator and h david c elliott m john b
brandy d yvore camille s bono or bano
hello
the
c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide and
jeffrey m bridget a omar l or i
i be just a straight line
omri
lena ann and design
otg
design otg
design otg design on the go is that what
that means
that sounds pretty uh intelligent sounds
uh guys i love doing the podcast as you
know and i want to thank each and every
one of you for allowing me to be inside
of you today thanks for listening thanks
for keep you know you tune in every week
and it means the world to me it truly
does and uh i appreciate you so next
week's gonna be another great episode i
hope you tune in and uh to all my
lovable patrons i love you thanks for uh
all your generosity and thanks for just
listening to the episode if this is your
first time and you're still tuned in
from michael rosenbaum here in the
hollywood hills of california and ryan
taylor's over here in the holocaust
california as well i'll give him a wave
out there
we love you be good to yourselves we'll
talk soon all right
[Music]